of ferocity unseen in recent years
Cyclone mocha slammed into parts of
Bangladesh and Myanmar it's just the
beginning of the season and it's been
devastating
satellite pictures show its Fierce eye
over the region
in its path lived more than 3 million
people
the vulnerable evacuated two shelters
homes land vegetation infrastructure
nothing spared as it made its way inland
rooftops ripped off and trees uprooted
by its savagery winds touching 130 miles
an hour brought three meter Storm surges
that inundated low-lying towns and
cities
its effects have been felt on the
world's largest refugee camp where a
million rohingyas fled persecution by
the Myanmar military
their flimsy homes made from mud bamboo
in tarpaulin offer little protection but
miraculously they have been largely
spared
it's across the border in Myanmar that
Aid agencies are most concerned with the
ongoing conflict between ethnic
minorities and the military access to
these vulnerable areas is hard to get we
estimate that about 6 million people in
this affected area were already in
humanitarian need even before this
Cyclone
um and the Damage that has been caused
is only going to make that worse
misery heaped once again on those
endured Decades of conflict poverty and
uncertainty Neville Lazarus Sky News